[Music]
hey what is up guys mkbhd here and
welcome back to the q a series i didn't
forget about this one it is pretty late
in september but it is still september
which means we have time to do the
monthly q a this is actually number 20
ever so as usual i asked you guys on
twitter what you wanted to know what you
wanted to know and there were plenty of
questions and i have to say right off
the bat the number one most asked
question there was like 2 000 questions
asked this time about half of them were
just iphone 8 versus iphone 10. so
obviously iphone 8 is out right now
iphone 10 is out in another couple weeks
uh the majority of the questions even
questions like in real life are like
should i wait is there anything really
new about iphone 8 i don't want to spoil
too much of the review that's about to
come out for this phone but i actually
really do like it a lot and there's some
things that people were kind of
underrating about it that are new
specifically the power and the cameras
but i'll cover all that in the full
video bottom line is yeah i'm gonna wait
for iphone 10. if i'm buying i want the
best iphone iphone 10 seems like that
best iphone what is your all-time
favorite video you've made
uh i don't have a good off-the-cuff
great answer for this there's a lot of
really fun videos i've made the one that
comes to mind right away is the project
love day video that we made that it was
only a 90 second video but i don't know
if i've told you about the entire
behind-the-scenes process that video
took several days to make in fact i
definitely did tell you that before but
seriously that was a lot of fun and the
fact that i ended up winning the contest
was a super big bonus what are your
thoughts on porsche's upcoming mission e
and i guess is it a tesla rival so i've
read a couple articles about this thing
uh and i've also read a bunch of
articles about other companies that are
making an electric
sedan or some electric sporty looking
car i think ideally yeah this ends up
being a tesla rival because they're so
similar if it ends up being real at all
it is another electric car that's in
roughly the same price point as tesla
model s but tesla's so far ahead in that
electric car market they already have
all these superchargers everywhere they
already have the clout the mind share
that's going to be hard to catch but at
the same time it's porsche porsche has a
lot of mind share and clout and people
like them and this is a really good
looking car so if they could attack some
of the places where people find tesla
model s to be like weaker like the
interior porsche tends to do really nice
interiors then i think they'll have
something going for him but until then
it's still playing catch up would you go
on first we feast hot ones if invited
well of course yes if you get invited to
do a show like that and to clear the
wings with sean evans you of course
accept the offer the question is would
you embarrass yourself if you like don't
finish all the wings i don't actually
know i think i'm pretty good with hot
food but i'm not sure here's the
interesting one how did you and the rest
of team crispy meet so generally i think
the the first time a lot of us met was
online so it's not really it doesn't
count as meeting each other the first
time i ever met austin evans i remember
was i'm gonna forget which phone it was
but it was a samsung galaxy s launch
event it was probably galaxy s3
launching in new york city we both went
to the launch event and it was we just
walked into a restaurant we're like oh
hey you're that other youtuber we've
collabed with what's up good to see you
in person and i think a lot of us do end
up meeting at these tech events whether
it's a samsung event or lg or whatever
they're just hosting a bunch of people
who are doing similar things like tech
press and tech youtubers so that's a lot
of where we meet for the first time how
many views did you get on your
very first video in the first 24 hours
of uploading
probably
probably like 12.
probably i would say if i put an over
under at like 15 i would take the under
do you think face id will be able to
replace touch id in terms of real world
usage so that's actually kind of a
question that i would have for apple
because if you think about it i mean i'm
sure they want it in iphone 10 i'm sure
they wanted to have touch id underneath
the glass that fingerprint reader that
everyone's used to in the same place
just under the glass but they didn't
they didn't get that in time so they
ended up working really hard on the
front-facing sensors to make face id as
good of a replacement as possible and as
as far as we know it's actually better
it's more reliable it's more consistent
it has a lower failure rate it's harder
to trick so ideally this is actually a
good replacement but what if next year
they actually do get the technology in
the iphone
11 or whatever it ends up being to put
touch id back underneath the glass does
that mean
we go back to touch id and we just
forget about face id even happening or
do we keep both but prioritize face id
because it's better but also offer that
like state of the art favorite reader
what do they do that's a that's
literally something i would want to ask
apple i guess we'll just have to wait a
year or so to find out do you ever get
disappointed by your youtube analytics
now we now have fingerprint sensor
facial recognition and iris scanner on
smartphones what do you think will be
the next step you're right that is a lot
of like body information like a lot of
biometric data to secure your phone next
thing you know they're gonna be like
listening to your heart rate
to oh wait why do they skip the new gold
color
in iphone x
or uh 10 iphone 10. i keep saying i
don't know if i'll ever really get used
to saying iphone 10 first of all i keep
saying iphone x
because it's an x it's going to say x on
the box i'm going to look at it and say
iphone x actually i even remember at the
event when we first went out to that
hands-on area and they had all those
apple employees like holding up the
phone waiting for people to shoot videos
of it and photos of it you could ask
them questions and stuff and i remember
i asked one of them a question and i
said hey on iphone x can you and before
i even finish the question they
interrupted me and said it's the 10.
like i think they were told to actively
correct these pressed people who were
talking about the phone to make sure
they say 10 not x anyway why they skip
the gold color uh i think i don't know i
think there will be more colors of
iphone later down the road this year
like they came out with that red iphone
halfway through the cycle last year
maybe they'll introduce a gold iphone 10
in a couple months who knows my real
question with the iphones is
this new space gray
why is it always a different color it
seems like every space gray apple
product is different from every other
space gray apple product even though
they're all space gray apple literally
got to invent their own color name here
but they made them all a different color
it kind of ruins the name reachability
on the iphone 10
fiasco or not i think you're referring
to like the double tap of uh like being
able to bring the screen halfway down
that's called reachability on iphone 8
iphone 7 iphone 6s all the big phones
yeah that's not as far as we know gonna
happen on iphone 10. there's no home
button so there's no place to double tap
to bring the screen down and i talked
about it in my second video about that
phone that it's it's a big screen so
it's gonna be kind of hard to reach uh
that's something to consider i don't
know if that's a huge deal for people
it's not gonna be like
reach gate or anything crazy like that
but yeah this is a bigger screen
something they're gonna have to get used
to and he plans to have a video test
driving an owner's model 3 hoping so
love your videos thank you patrick and
yes i think it's about that time where
now people who are outside of tesla who
who aren't employees are going to be
starting to get their model 3 orders in
so let this be a psa if you are a future
or about to be current model 3 owner
that's also in the northeast new york
city area that's also willing to let me
shoot a video about your car hit me up
on twitter link below wireless charging
for teslas
when
yeah i don't so i've seen uh i've seen
some concepts about wireless charging
for cars the thing about
wireless charging is it loses it's not
very efficient first of all your phones
our phones already get pretty warm when
we put them down on like a wireless
charging pad and they don't charge as
fast because they're losing some of that
charging to heat dissipation trying to
charge a car very quickly is already
kind of a big deal people want their
cars to charge fast but even in your
garage i can't imagine heat not being a
really big problem there i was super
charging this weekend on a road trip and
it was really hot this weekend it was
about 95 degrees so the car thermometer
said 109 degrees when it was on that
asphalt and it was plugged in and trying
to unplug the car it was hot to the
touch and that was just from being
plugged in so wireless charging being
like somewhere near the car and trying
to transmit energy that doesn't seem
like a great idea maybe in the future
maybe in 20 years but not right now now
that you have a main gear pc will we
ever see a pub g stream from you maybe
with sam sheffer hey you know what i'm
sure sam would be willing and i haven't
so i'm not a big shooter gamer type but
this machine makes me want to be i'm
thinking we'll organize some sort of
live stream where i'm actually trying to
game but obviously the best games i'm at
are driving games and like sports
simulation type games but i'll give pubg
a shot because it's so hot right now and
also because that main gear pc is so hot
right now link to the battle station
post below it's kind of lit but yeah
that's pretty much it i think that's
where we'll end it this has been q a
number 20
and of course the september edition it's
about to be october so of course you
know there's gonna be more questions if
you have any others feel free to leave
them in the comments below i'll hang out
there for a bit hit me up on twitter i
get back to those but that has been it
thank you for watching talk to you guys
the next one
peace
[Music]